I just care that you show up at all
feels like there's a migration going on
yeah
what does it feel like to you
it feels like a migration I mean it
feels like we're getting like a second
chance in our music career which is
really cool we started really young and
we got signed at a really young age and
then we took a really big break for
music why were you releasing music
I think we I mean to be completely
honest I think we were
trying to figure out what our voice was
as adult women and not underneath the
huge corporation of
Disney Channel so I think that was our
our greatest struggle
um I know that we still felt very bonded
as sisters and and as a band it never
had anything to do with that it was more
about
what is the music that we make in our
adult future